what secret lies beneath the earth's
crust how does the housing in the
neighborhood affect the health of its
residents
how do genes interact to cause
significant diseases such as cancer
questions like these have been at the
heart of the Canadian Institute for
Advanced Research since its founding in
1982 at that time a group of visionaries
asked a question of their own how could
Canada play a leading role in the world
of intellectual investigation and
discovery the answer was the Canadian
Institute for Advanced Research a new
organization with an unprecedented
approach to research that would help
catapult Canada to the forefront of
knowledge creation the original idea was
that Camden needed a place where our
leading-edge thinkers could work
together and create critical mass on
intellectual capacity to ask big
questions and to answer them here in
Canada to create something bigger than
the sum of its parts by putting Canadian
strengths together we create communities
without a physical space in which that
community is created that's one big
difference the other big difference is
that our work in Advanced Research is
all collaborative so we support people
who work together with other people to
advance human knowledge see far has more
than a dozen active research programs
each is driven by pressing questions
about society technology and the very
nature of humanity in the universe the
questions CFR asks are complex and
surprising they need to discoveries and
ideas that can have a profound effect on
the way people think and act all over
the world my research involves a direct
effort to image to map out structures
deep inside of our planet structures
that we normally cannot see that are
completely inaccessible to normal human
observation and my research is focused
on the use of earthquakes which
illuminate structures inside the planet
deep below the crust and my efforts to
understand how this material functions
and has moved both in the past at the
present and indeed even in the future
will help us to unravel
many of the questions that relate to the
origin of some fundamental physical
effects at the Earth's surface such as
the origins of earthquakes how
earthquakes evolve what are the forces
responsible for earthquakes how does see
far go about answering such gargantuan
questions working with senior academics
from around the world we identified
major new research areas where Canada
could and should lead the way see far
then assembles an elite team of
researchers whose collective expertise
is ideally suited to the project through
the Institute this team works together
for years expanding the frontiers of
human knowledge see far is driven by the
principle that collective expertise
creates a whole that is far more than
the sum of its parts the world is
changing quite rapidly are we can't
continue to rely on resources in this
country we can't continue to be just
hewers of wood and miners and the like
the world is changing and the future
powerful economies of the world are
going to depend on the creation of
knowledge and Canada needs to strengthen
its ability to generate knowledge and
that comes through research and and the
educational systems and the like we
identify some of the most important
questions that need to be asked to
advance the world in all respects and we
then put enormous resources into
identifying the best people from many
different disciplines to take those
questions on pursue them for multiple
years to try to come up with answers
that are important to the world at large
talent attracts talent and when you are
known as a place to which talented and
able and intelligent people come more
people come to join you and in a society
in which our growth in our development
is based on more on what's between our
ears than anything else it's very
important for society like Canada to
have really intelligent interesting
people taking
electoral risks and learning new things
and bringing with them everybody else
who can learn from what they learn one
of the building blocks of a successful
society is successful housing and
neighborhoods as far as I'm concerned
and the reason for that is that we know
that our everyday environments are
fundamentally linked to the health and
well-being of individuals affordability
of housing is strongly related to health
status things like the amount of control
that you exercise over your home I mean
your home is probably the most important
site in your everyday life for the
exercise of control and we know thats
related to health status one recent
study in New Zealand actually showed
that if you provide in a standard
package of insulation in homes that were
previously uninsulated it had a positive
impact on health but it was more than
just respiratory health or people's
comfort with temperature was actually
their psychological health that improves
substantially and so it's really
something about having control over your
home and having a sense of comfort and
having your home be a place of refuge
that seems to be what's driving the
health effect see far is a
not-for-profit organization individuals
foundations corporations and governments
support CFR because of the long-term
benefits for Canada and the world look I
i I'm weekly Canadians have some
characteristics we are always awed by
our neighbors to the south we always
think that down there they do things
better than anywhere else in the world
and and and I just feel good when I see
an organization in Canada doing
something better than anyone else in the
world I think they are
we've discovered that most of the time
diseases like cancer are not caused by
problems and single genes but by many
genes interacting to cause disease and
the way they interact a cause but me to
have cancer might be quite different
from the way they interact cause other
people to have cancer and so our
challenge is to figure out in normal
cells how all these genes interact and
then how those interactions are going
wrong in cancer cells and we call that
building a genetic interaction network
so really I'd say the whole field is
only about five years old and we're
fairly far along in building genetic
interaction maps for very simple systems
like the budding yeast which is one of
the systems we're using but we're not
very far along and building genetic
interactions other systems so that's a
major challenge of our genetic networks
group is to take what we learn in these
simple systems and transport that
knowledge into more complex systems our
goal is currently is within the next
year to basically complete a genetic
interaction map for yeast so this is the
simplest cell that's sort of like human
cells and we can do that I think that's
an attainable goal I think it will tell
us a lot and I can't even really tell
you how you know all the new things that
we think we're going to learn from
examining this map but there's a lot of
excitement in the community about
getting access to these data and
analyzing them
the more meetings i come to the more
presentations i see by researchers the
more excited i get what we do is build
canada's capacity we not only made
breakthroughs of understanding we've
also been able to share them in such a
way as to have an impact on decision
makers we think that what we're doing is
enabling the very best to be even better
in many many fields from genetics to
super conductivity from string theory to
economic theory the floodgates of
discovery are only now beginning to open
at a time of monumental expansion of
knowledge see far researchers are
leading the world setting new standards
for research excellence
you